what the heck's going on in this space I
came in here and it's like a big empty
box and then some beautiful Samsung TV
sure I mean Samsung makes great to paint
a picture we're in my kind of media
company in downtown Manhattan right now
the name of this company is three six
eight and we're on the second floor
which is sort of like the basement and
the kind of thesis the premise of this
whole company is to be a kind of a
beacon or a lighthouse for the creator
community the creativity focused creator
community so most of the time it's like
it is now which is very quiet and empty
yeah but when it's not quite an empty it
comes alive in a way that's like total
madness and chaos and we usually have
somewhere between like three to six or
three to seven kind of events or
engagements a week and when we do that
it's anywhere from you know 80 to I
think 170 peoples as many people as we
can let in this past weekend we did like
that you know moment lenses the startup
that makes really fancy lenses for your
iPhone and for your Samsung phones they
had a Film Festival here this past
weekend it was totally packed it was a
madhouse we do gaming events we have one
I think
Mortal Kombat who Patrick won the Mortal
Kombat event that happened it already
happened yeah you have like about dozen
rigs that we have we have a huge sort of
gaming I don't know no but we have a
it's a big part of the community so we
have a huge sort of gaming set up gaming
studio here and we don't have our own
team which is a wonderful thing so that
means we can work with sort of all kinds
of gamers and streamers from across the
board
it's a non-competitive we we take a
non-competitive stance so it means that
we can do competitions in here we have
people from all bars and then and then
the upstairs which is a big kind of
6,000 square foot 16-foot ceiling open
space is super dynamic and like for the
film festival it looked like a movie
theater upstairs and we do we big gaming
events will turn upstairs into like five
living rooms were in a different to the
studio gaming studio down here we have
got big gaming events upstairs
but essentially we wanted to be a
resource for creators and the events we
do and
Abell that and they enable sort of a
coming together of what is an otherwise
fragmented community and the business
that we've built behind that is by
elevating the talents of creators to a
point where they can make money and what
that literally means to not be so
wishy-washy whimsical about it is that I
think in the Creator community there's
this misunderstanding that the only way
you can make dollars and cents is by
building your YouTube audience big
enough so you can exploit it by selling
them sweat shirts or Adsense or
something like that and I think there's
a higher value on creativity that goes
way above view counts yeah and that's
kind of you know opportunities like
connecting creators with brands that are
looking to do things and we do a lot of
work with brands in here we're wrapping
up another Adobe campaign right now it's
being directed by two creators being
edited by another creator we you know we
work with great companies like GoPro and
redbull and Electronic Arts and for
every one of those engagements we are
reaching out to creators that we like or
know and we don't care how big their
audience is we look at how big their
reaches we only care about one thing
which is their their creativity and what
they make so we bring jobs to creators
and we produce those jobs there's a
business in that and it's a very
symbiotic relationship between what we
are doing both as you know to help
elevate the community and then what
we're doing kind of in the industry to
connect the industry with these creators
and via that symbiosis there is a real
business that has been you know we're
nine months old but we're profitable and
we've got pretty solid cash flow
positive in here and we're slowly
scaling if people want to go somewhere
and meet with people and make this real